robbie ray actually came to the big
leagues as a member of the tigers in
2014. it's the second time he will pitch
against them but he has had a great
season 288 in running average infield
back out field shading towards right
field grossman swings and hits a line
drive caught by machete ranging to his
right in the hole the 180 era
over his last four starts he's gone at
least six innings in all of them and he
gets scope swinging two down and on the
mound tonight for your tigers tyler
alexander his teammates call him todd
the painter
the one two tried to check it and
he couldn't hold up first strikeout of
the night for tyler alexander one two to
guerrero
strike three on the outside
miguel cabrera leads off the second
inning for the tigers one home run away
from 500.
in on his hands and rey's popped him up
on the right side of the infield it'll
be guerrero to make the catch and
history will have to wait at least one
more at back here comes a guy who's had
a surge in home run power lately willie
castro
castro lines one to right center field
that is down cut off by hernandez castro
forced to hold on for a long single
[Applause]
strike three called over the outside
corner
the one-two pitch hernandez swings and
misses at a change-up four batters base
three have been struck out by tyler
alexander what away two men aboard
here's the payoff
ground ball to short could it be two
quick turn by scope in time richik
bounces into the six four three double
play and the toronto threat is over
the 1-2 pitch
appenez called strike three
short goes down looking at the fastball
from ray
the 1-0
softly to left and in for a base hit
second hit of the night for the tigers
0-2
and it's strike three called four
strikeouts already for ray he's been
really impressive in the first two
innings
of the gunner off the glove of espinal
into left field it's a hot shot and
tigers have a couple of men aboard
ray deals
swinging a miss
down on strikes again
robbie ray punches out the side
first major league start for kevin smith
he is the dh tonight of the university
of maryland back in 2017 and he's got
his first big league base hit
well what a great moment for a youngster
he had one as bad as a pinch hitter in
washington and now he jumps on the first
pitch he sees and
hits it into right field what a great
feeling that's his family there that are
here and they're here to share this
great moment his mom and dad
got to see the boy get his first big
league hit
[Applause]
now the o2
ground ball to second
scope of the tag and converts the double
play the second one of the night for the
tigers already cabrera again comes up in
search of career home run number 500
and ray says no 500 on my watch thank
you very much as he strikes him out on
three pitches
oh two to castro
on the inside corner again strike three
strikeout number seven for robbie ray
vladimir guerrero jr leads it off for
toronto against the lefty tyler
alexander the pitch is hit in the air
deep out to center field cameron going
back turns around it's out of here
vladimir guerrero jr destroys a rising
line drive to right center field
home run number 36 on the season for
vladi
it left a vapor trail
the 2-2
and he strikes out hernandez for the
second time tonight
florida junior rockets one into left
field that'll back up castro playing it
on a long hop
[Applause]
now alejandro kirk smokes a ball to left
field and that's going to get under the
glove of castro
guerrielle on his way to third and kirk
into second
a rocket to left will go for a two base
hit so now it's up to the rookie kevin
smith
deal one
popped up another alexander sees it
grinder calls forward and alexander gets
out of a jam he does give up the lead
off homer but strands two in scoring
position a good crisp pace along with
kirk and he got him
might have gotten the benefit of the
doubt on that fastball in but it's
strikeout number eight
robbie ray just keeps on mowing him down
five scoreless innings for the
left-handers so far tonight
one two
check swinging went around called by the
home plate umpire espionage down on
strikes lead off man retired
they got some depth now
scope chases and he strikes out number
nine already for ray
3-2 pitch swinging a miss
strikeout number 10 for robbie ray and
now for the third time tonight miguel
cabrera
he does and he gets a weak ground ball
to second up with its simeon and another
good inning for robbie ray
[Applause]
nice play by short spinning his way he
got him by a step
what a play by zach short a wink as he
jogs off flashing some leather ray has
now retired 11 out of the last 12. the
one two
swinging above miss ball may have been
tipped off nope it's dug out of the dirt
kirk steps in front of the plate snaps
it down to first and that strikeout 11
for robby ray robbie ray pete says
probably the most gratifying to see how
far he's come from what he was
routine fly ball to center grichik again
seven scoreless innings for robbie ray
85 pitches
for tyler alexander
and the 86th gets grichik frozen they
needed a solid pitching performance from
tyler alexander and they got it
zach short drills one to left for a base
hit
first hit of the night for zach short
runner from second goes the pitch call
to strike no throw to third base zach
short rolling the dice with a tying run
and bolting towards third
the 1-1
in the dirt that squirts by kirk on the
way as short and he scores the tying run
that's called manufacturing a run there
but how about zach short picking the
perfect time to steal third base and
then here on this pass ball a wild pitch
score the time run for the tigers
right-hander jose cisnero is into the
game one of those finesse pitchers that
really gives the blue jays
a good start espinal bounces one into
right field for a lead off base hit the
2-2
swung on him missed huge strikeout for
cisnero waits on a 2-2
ground ball to short
there's one
there's two
the third double play of the night
it gets cisnero and the tigers out of
the jam one help from miguel cabrera do
you just stay with the fastball because
he hasn't shown you he can hit it they
do and he strikes him out two down
got under it
shallow left
and a diving oh attempt and then guriel
couldn't hold on to it beshet comes up
with it and nunez hustling from the very
get-go all the way to second he's got
himself in scoring position with two
away go ahead run at second two down top
nine
and the fastball grounded to the right
side guerrero's got it and he wins the
race to the bag and the side is retired
he's squaring
let's see
the o2
he does and he lays it down scope of the
beautiful play got him at third base
that took guts
athleticism and accuracy
here it is
rolled it over to short there's one
in time to get him harold castro's gonna
bat for grayson greiner last played on
wednesday and went one for three
to left field a base hit
here comes willy castro he'll test the
arm of guriel way up the line the tigers
have the lead on harold castro's pinch
hit rbi single that ball's running away
from castro but look how he stays down
and through that ball how about the call
there from aj hinch
scope
a floater to center field and it drops
harold castro will score an insurance
run asked for and delivered by jonathan
scope
candelarios that's left-handed he swings
and he lines one up in the middle a base
hit into center field that will push the
third run of the tenth across for
detroit here's miguel cabrera all for
four so far 02 to cabrera
swung on and missed has to get beau
beschette the 2-2
fly ball center field cameron's back
he's got it and this is a memorable win
for the tigers that's as good as it gets
right there
you